[Music]
four decades after its creation Silicon
Valley Bank was the 16th largest bank in
the U.S
it took just a day and a half for it to
fall apart this was the second biggest
bank failure that's ever happened in the
United States once seen as a major Tech
banking player svb's stunning collapse
spurred other bank closures rattled
Global markets and threatened the
livelihoods of startups across the
country so what went wrong
Silicon Valley Bank opened in 1983 to
serve fledgling tech companies
eventually nearly half of the country's
Venture capital-backed technology and
Life Sciences companies would rely on
svb Roku Roblox and many others put
Millions into the bank helping svb
become one of the nation's largest some
of these clients would definitely be
considered risky these are companies
that move quickly and their money moves
quickly when things sort of went off the
rails they were quick to move their
money out of the bank after the banking
crisis that triggered the
Russian president Barack Obama signed
the Dodd-Frank Act
svb face stricter regulation it is
designed to make sure that everybody
follows the same set of rules but eight
years later during the Trump
Administration some of those regulations
on smaller Banks were rolled back by
liberating small Banks from excessive
bureaucracy and that's what it was
bureaucracy
we are unleashing the economic potential
of our people some of the rules we're
rolled back for these banks that had
less than 250 billion dollars in assets
so you have the biggest banks like Bank
of America and Chase those have very
strict rules but the ones that are a
step below have looser rules
two years later svb was flooded with
cash as businesses deposited more during
the pandemic deposits tripled in two
years to 189 billion dollars make 2021
svb's most profitable year ever our Core
Business continues to fire on all
cylinders so svb Financial took that
cash and bought tens of billions of
dollars of longer-term U.S treasuries
and government-backed mortgage
Securities products usually considered
safe people and companies just put money
in their bank accounts and Banks said we
have to do something with this we have
to earn some income on it so they bought
bonds with it svb's Securities portfolio
Rose about a hundred billion dollars in
under a year after svb had stockpiled
that 100 billion dollars plus in bonds
all of a sudden interest rates Rose
committee anticipates that ongoing
increases in the target range for the
federal funds rate will be appropriate
what happens when interest rates rise is
bond prices fall Banks including svb
that were holding on to a lot of bonds
we're sitting on a bunch of losses soon
svb's Investments were worth 17 billion
dollars less than their fair value
and so all of a sudden the gap between
what svb had paid for those bonds and
what they were worth on paper had jumped
to more than 17 billion dollars and that
was the key risk that would eventually
lead to svb's undoing making matters
worse as interest rates Rose new
deposits shrank falling nearly 30
billion dollars from March to December
talking about the end of 2022 CEO Greg
Becker told CNBC we could have felt that
that bottom hung out we've kind of felt
that we were kind of at that that lower
point the vast majority of the bank's
deposits were held in just 37 000
accounts that held more than 250
thousand dollars the amount insured by
the FDIC then in a regulatory filing on
March 8 svb announced it sold a large
chunk of Securities at a loss of about
1.8 billion dollars to help it cover
that decline in deposits the regulatory
filing that Wednesday sparked a lot of
fear the stock fell a tremendous amount
which is never a good sign and investors
were already on edge crypto focused bank
silvergate had just announced it would
wind down and return all deposits so the
bottom was about to fall out startup
CEOs began receiving urgent calls from
panicked Venture Capital investors
he was out of breath like he had just
run a marathon and he said take your
money out of SBB go into your account
take your money out as soon as possible
what started as a trickle of withdrawals
quickly turned into a tidal wave as
words spread across the valley more and
more startups pulled their cash it was a
run on the bank and the beginning of the
end for svb the next day the bank's
stock price went into Free Fall as
customers tried to withdraw 42 billion
dollars in deposits svb ran out of cash
all of a sudden everyone's saying whoa
wait a minute this bank is risky the
bank has enough money to cover deposits
if they come out in sort of a peaceful
orderly fashion when everyone's Racing
for the exits at once it doesn't that
day Regulators seized the bank the FDIC
said in a statement that customers would
have full access to their insured
deposits in three days but the bank had
more than 151 billion dollars worth of
deposits at the end of 2022 that weren't
insured they were over the 250 000 limit
two days after svb's collapse a second
bank with a different set of problems
signature failed and was seized by
Regulators the third largest failure in
history and now people are starting to
worry about other Banks as well it's
very much kind of a a whack-a-mole
situation right now Federal officials
State officials everyone's in sort of
this unenviable position of trying to
shore up confidence in the banking
industry so it doesn't turn into an even
bigger Panic on Sunday March 12th
Regulators announced that even uninsured
deposits over two hundred fifty thousand
dollars from the two Banks would be
covered on Monday March 14th signature
told clients that due to the U.S
treasury Federal Reserve and FDIC all
deposits were not at risk svb's focus on
Silicon Valley made it uniquely
vulnerable to a run its fortunes were
really tied to the fortunes of this one
industry but what's more this is an
industry that has flighty deposits you
can't really rely on this short-term
funding necessarily to support these
long-term investments in bonds now some
like President Joe Biden are blaming the
Dodd-Frank Act rollback for the failures
I'm going to ask Congress on the banking
Regulators to strengthen the rules for
banks to make it less likely this kind
of bag failure would happen again with
investigations into svb underway the
clients will see their money returned
but shareholders are out of luck when
asked about the possibility of bailing
out Silicon Valley Bank the treasury
secretary said we're not going to do
that again but we are concerned about
depositors and are focused on trying to
meet their needs
[Music]
foreign